what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back with another episode of IBM Tech
now
I'm going to dive into the latest and
greatest IBM news and announcements
including info on Linux one bare metal
servers the AI Ops insights dashboard
and IBM Cloud pay as you go with
committed use but first I wanted to
touch on something a bit outside the IBM
ecosystem the Nobel prizes
in early October three scientists were
awarded the Nobel Prize in physics
American John clauser Frenchman Island
aspect and Austrian Anton zeilinger the
three physicists who worked
independently of each other made key
contributions to the field of quantum
mechanics and helped the world
understand the topsy-turbing nature of
the subatomic world
in particular they demonstrated a
baffling phenomenon known as quantum
entanglement which refers to the
mysterious way that particles separated
by great distances and without an
apparent connection can still impact
each other
some of the biggest brains in the world
have been puzzling over this perplexing
reality for decades in fact almost 90
years ago Albert Einstein referred to it
as spooky action at a distance
in bestowing the honors the Nobel
committee explained that the three
scientists paved the way for Quantum
Computing Quantum networks and Quantum
encrypted communication
we're really excited for the winners and
the work they're doing because Quantum
Computing is a passionate area of focus
here at IBM we can't wait to see what
more is to come
to learn more about IBM's Quantum work
check out the recommended videos in the
description
now let's pivot and talk about
sustainability
in addition to their normal challenges
of modernizing apps and reducing costs
it leaders are increasingly taking on a
new goal achieving sustainability this
is an admirable Endeavor for any
organization and to help we're excited
to announce the general availability of
IBM Linux 1 bare metal servers
this offering is a new way to deploy the
Linux 1 platform in an off-premises
infrastructure as a service model that
can help reduce energy consumption
Linux 1 bare metal servers are dedicated
servers based on the Linux One processor
architecture known as s390x and what's
so special about Linux one you ask well
Linux one operates as a truly green it
platform
the same workload running on Linux 1
could require up to 75 percent less
electricity and related carbon
generation compared to using x86 servers
add Linux one bare metal servers for
off-premises capacity and you're well on
your way to meeting those environmental
goals and reducing the carbon footprint
of your it operations
to learn more about Linux 1 bare metal
servers and how they can help on your
journey to sustainability check out the
link I've got in the description of this
video
next up I want to tell you a bit about
the new AI Ops insights dashboard which
is a new product feature in the latest
IBM Cloud pack for Watson AI Ops release
version 3.5
the insights dashboard gives you a
single holistic view into the critical
Services tied to your organization's
kpis businesses lose millions of dollars
each year because execs and decision
makers can't identify blind spots in
their I.T performance which obviously
affects business outcomes adversely
through the dashboard you the it exec
can present key contextualized incident
metrics to your stakeholders
prioritizing Core Business issues and
matching how the business functionally
operates
this will help you better understand the
impact of it problems on Business
Services and processes Engage The
upstream and downstream impacts of an
outage
in fact using Watson AI Ops in the
insights dashboard you can reduce
unplanned downtime by 15 and mean time
to resolution by 50 while simultaneously
helping to drive over 200 return on
investment by applying context to
application insights and addressing
business needs in real time
to learn more about the AI Ops insights
dashboard hit the link below
finally IBM's goal is to provide a
dynamic and flexible billing model to
help you optimize your business as such
I'm excited to announce the IBM Cloud
pay as you go with committed use billing
model
this allows you to commit to spend a
certain amount on IBM cloud and in
return receive a discount on all IBM
Cloud platform usage your build monthly
based on your discounted usage and
unlike the subscription model you
continue to receive a discount even
after you reach your yearly committed
amount
this means no penalty for overage
charges if you spend more than the
amount you committed to you will
continue to receive the same discounts
agreed upon per the terms of your
commitment
there's even an improved console
experience so you can easily visualize
the progress towards your commitment
establish discounts and the remaining
time on the commitment
to learn more and get started with IBM
Cloud pay as you go with committed use
hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now